behind the N for C and now Keller to the
line dery and now Keller Keller looking
around Keller right through they star what a pass
and [__] the recipient what a beauty it's one
nothing rookie gets a beauty pass by Clayton
Keller look at how sick that is look at the
silky Ms of number nine head up little
saucer pass up and down over two if not
three Washington Capital sticks and right
onto the twig of Logan cooie thank you very
much back door tapping oh Alex oetkin one of
the last remaining players in the league when
I played rosby maybe another one I can't
think of many others wa a second oetkin
has been playing for 40 years carcone
scores Michael carcone two nothing he's
redot everything this guy touches is tickling
the twine and that's a goal scorer's goal I think
he used this the defenseman speed through
the neutral zone as a screen a little bit
that's certainly one the Darcy keer has got to
stop that's from long range Dumba CAU about it
Keller and now kerfoot Keller's got it late in the
power play and a goal SMS up top
power play goal and they pay it
off ever seen one but watch again Clayton Keller
this is where the coyes want
the puck that little backhand
sauce so silky and schs finding a way just
to get open he knows Keller wants to feed
him now Dumba tries to move it along coyotes
will get it in coie for schaltz little rink
wide back out High kessle ring little drop co uh
Keller schaltz he scores through a screen Nick
schaltz and the goal total here in the first
period of play matches the win streak for the
coyotes Ottawa it's it's one of those
nights I I'm just telling you him and
Clayton Keller having on a string good for
Logan kolie pay a price in front of the net
providing that screen [__] goes to the
front that brings the defender with him
and L no Carlson and now zooker locking
up C foot as well manstein can't get it
out for Washington good keep in the line by
kerle to the front suer scores Jason sucker
unbelievable oh my this is a blood bath right now
nobody home look at the effort there by carcone
the missplay there by Carlson kerfoot wrong guy to
give it to he finds zooker all alone look at the
Caps everyone up top picking flowers nobody back
there go tend lingren hung out to dry he goes out
with the fire poker and he misses by a mile and
look at the sweet Ms by zooker this is getting
ugly into the corner D St and now Str comes
in Fr a point blank save lingren that time on
Krauss schz look to get it out here they
come again kolie is in kolie a little flip
Keller shoots went up high that time on Charlie
lingren and it's out of play like to use now
just effortlessly watch watch the hands this time
on Logan [__] just up and over the defenseman
stick and Mana from behind the net wide turn and a
mantha leaves it parar the front stopped oh what a
stop sliding to make the save Conor Ingram Oh What
A save is right and here's the play redirection in
front look at that right pad and Phillips Phillips
looking around trying to play it back out highkin
with a shot Love Save Ingram That Was a Rolling
Puck too taking away you see that stick by cero
taking away that pass now bues that you know
they're trying to get it to him that pass had
to go sandino look to get it out in the way of
that one was buad here's a chance buad he's home
three leaves to kerfoot to buad to kerfoot and
that's the first shorty of the season and it's 6
nothing
two
on0 shorthanded how many times did they pass
the puck back and forth between them good
luck on that one lingren and big goal for
bu's Dad six of the season and sixth goal
of the night on just 14 shots a golender on the
plan that's going to stop that one they haven't
had a three power play goal game this season
they've had four two power play goal games
and that's where they're sitting at right now
to the front oh and buad he can't bag at home
side of the net look at the movement here
though by the coyotes KRA back door Beauty
and McMichael now McMichael will play it to the
front the net and it's on and Ingram the save wow
was that an opportunity CES are all around it
but nobody covers him and he gets a real good
opportunity as valami will bring it along a two-on
one here with Keller Keller's got it Keller holds
back to the front and off the pipe Nick schal he
was the trailer on the play oh that would have
been number three and you bet you Clayton Keller
was looking for him well there was a chance we
had earlier that Logan kie play and Puck ends up
in the hands of Clayton kerin moved along here's
an opportunity Sand's going to skate in he shoots
Pat save Ingram and these games are are always so
tough to play and for both sides man's got it MC
Michel lead pass over the line cus and that's the
N that one popped right up in front and it's
cleared Away by lawon Crow and now Keller for
kerot Keller again C fooot goes across coie off
the post and that doesn't get over clean to Logan
kulie but he still managed to handle it back to
the line zooker good keep sent it in behind and at
melli is on it comes across right to the front Zer
was batted Away by lingren they're out there for
the face off and think Michael and now Wilson will
get it back out high for sandine this one hits in
front somehow able to keep it out was Conor Ingram
that that hit a sticking and bounce straight
down now van reik across sandine to the front
tied up and cleared and here comes Keller back
another massive save by Conor rraman kman big
hit there on Edmonson now in behind and have
they get it to the FR Milano he can't put
it home and sent over the top by Edmonson
and out of the Zone Crown loving it oh are
they ever Roy ster can't believe it traffic
in front there's the original stop and and the
coyotes run their win streak to five they are
the hottest team in the National Hockey League
second shot out of a season for Conor Ingram